jean luc mélenchon à nouveau tête de
liste pour l'élection européenne pour la
grande région sud ouest est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec la fp et dailymotion avec
nous c'est à dire tout à l'heure qu'à
telle prigent de la fp et perrine
tarneaud de public sénat qui nous
rejoindront donc jean luc mélenchon mais
avant d'évoquer le 25 mai l'élection en
france dont des députés européens
on va parler de ce 5 mai cela fait deux
ans exactement que françois hollande a
gagné l'élection présidentielle et vous
ne ménagez pas depuis c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire est ce que vous pouvez
au moins citer une de ses réussites
non rien ben non un immense blanc je ne
sais pas je n'en sais de vin blanc vous
me posez une question je vous réponds la
réponse est non le mariage pour tous
la chasse est une réussite de françois
hollande ça j'ai il a failli faire
capoter le projet il l'a estropiés en
cours de route et vous appelez ça une
réussite
vous appelez une réussite la manière
avec laquelle a été géré cette affaire
le fait que le président de la
république est affaibli son propre camp
en cours de route en expliquant qu'il y
aurait une clause de conscience possible
pour les élus sont ne pas célébrer les
mariages pour tous c'est à dire avant
temps quelque chose d'incroyable qui est
que la loi ne s'applique que si on a
envie de l'appliquer vous appelez ça une
réussite
non c'est pas du tout une réussite cette
affaire a été très malmené
qui plus est sur des sujets pardon
puisque vous les grecs ce que c'est vous
qui citait les réussites du gouvernement
de françois hollande mais je vous dis
vous aider mais tant qu'il ya pas de
réponse président vous ne m'ayez pas
vous m'avez posé une question et je vous
réponds vous n'avez pas à m'aider à
trouver des bonnes idées pour françois
hollande journalistes ou ou portable de
françois hollande journaliste donc ma
réponse est non il n'a mené à rien de ce
qu'il a entrepris d'une manière qui
mérite d'être retenu par contre les
économistes de droite peuvent le
féliciter et dire bravo monsieur
hollande a réussi ce que personne
n'avait fait avant lui par exemple
repousser la retraite à 66 ans par
exemple refusé toutes les augmentations
du smic par exemple créé la politique
qu'ils appellent de l'offre d'une
manière très prétentieuse et donner plus
de 90 milliards au total à ce qu'il
appelle les entreprises c'est à dire les
très grandes entreprises
ça c'est deux sont des réussites de
droite me le demandez pas à moi sommes
de gauche
les brunes pareil très bien on a bien
compris alors françois hollande au matin
de ce 6 mai a demandé à être jugé à la
fin du quinquennat est ce que vous ne
voulez pas lui accorder cette grâce
jean-luc fermé mais non mais non parce
que il est dangereux d'ores et déjà et
je vais vous montrer en quoi
oui je vais vous montrer pourquoi
d'abord sur le plan des relations
internationales nous l'avons entendu à
l'occasion de sa grâce à son entretien
de presse le matin de l'anniversaire de
son élection
dire qu'ils étaient disposés à
intervenir militairement en syrie
même sans l'onu dans le cadre de l'otan
c'est une première jamais la france n'a
eu une attitude belliciste de cette
nature la france a toujours agi dans le
cadre de l'onu donc françois hollande ne
regrette que les nord américains soient
pas intervenues en syrie et il regrette
que l'on n'ait pas fait une intervention
hors le cadre de l'onu de la même
manière sur les sujets internationaux
il a toujours aligner la france dans une
position extrémiste par rapport aux
états unis d'amérique
maintenant sur le plan intérieur sa
politique d'austérité a créé une spirale
dépressive un cercle vicieux qui fait
que plus l'activité a ralenti plus le
déficit naturellement se creuse puisque
les rentrées fiscales ne sont pas
suffisantes et plus le déficit se creuse
plus il faut augmenter par conséquent il
est responsable de lane amy et d'une
poussée du chômage
absolument incroyable plus de neuf cents
par jour depuis qu'il est le président
de la république
donc ça nous pouvons le dire on va pas
attendre la fin du quinquennat pour dire
que ce serait une mauvaise alors non
mais attendez il agit pas de le juger
nous ne sommes pas dans un concours de
beauté nous sommes des citoyens actifs
dans une démocratie chacun de demandes
attendait la fin du quinquennat vous dit
mme lambert veut déjà et il a les yeux
mais monsieur gossio attendez une
seconde
qu'est-ce qu'il est dangereux que d'ici
la fin du quinquennat personne ne vote
qu'est ce que vous me dites me suivre
sur le 25 mai nous allons mettre un
bulletin de vote
ce bulletin de vote contient un jugement
sur l'action de françois hollande c'est
bien françois hollande qui n'a pas
renégocier le traité européen qui
s'était engagé à négocier c'est bien
françois hollande qui a dit que le grand
marché transatlantique
il fallait le faire vite et fort et tout
de suite et le plus vite possible pour
que les gens aient pas le temps de
réagir
donc le 25 mai nous allons mettre un
bulletin de notes beaucoup d'entre nous
va
contre cette europe et contre françois à
lausanne on est en train de me dire
michel grossiord que je dois attendre la
prochaine élection présidentielle pour
donner mon avis mais c'est pas une
monarchie dans laquelle nous sommes
alors c'est une république en délégation
françois hollande nous habitue à ces
prophéties vous l'avez noté jean avec
mélangeant le retournement ou encore
l'inversion de la courbe du chômage
c'est son obsession il le répète vous ne
croyez je crois ni à l'une ni à l'autre
néo retournement ni à la version de la
courbe du chômage puisque d'ores et déjà
selon vous françois hollande il l'avait
dit d'ailleurs aux ouvriers de michelin
devraient renoncer à se présenter en
2010 est blessé c'est son problème mais
je ne suis pas socialiste je ne m'occupe
pas de ce qu'il fait et fera bien ce
qu'il voudra mais je moi je m'occupe de
savoir si cette politique va produire
autre chose qu'un désastre
le premier désastre il est moral
permettez moi de vous le dire c'est que
l'idée du socialisme a été abaissée
comme jamais et jusqu'au point que pour
beaucoup de gens la gauche et la droite
c'est pareil
voilà ça c'est un désastre en naufrage
moral qui est de sa responsabilité à lui
est de cette manière il a poussé des tas
de gens hors de leurs habitudes de leurs
de leurs réflexes intellectuels et
moraux le deuxième désastre
il est social le troisième il est
national c'est à dire que la france
entend que entités en tant qu'etat en
tant que nation est en train de se vider
de son sang sans que le président de la
république lève le petit doigt
il n'a rien dit quand une entreprise
aussi important il fait son obsession
mais qu'il a il a permis à culpa il n'a
pas dit que les choses étaient assez gré
aussi grave qu elles le sont notamment
la perte de marchés économiques sur les
quais mélenchon et puis la perte de
compétitivité des entreprises
ce sont les arguments du chef de l'état
jugé bien qu'on joue les aurait payé
mais si vous permettez je vais vous
opposer les miens d'arguments quand une
entreprise de pointe dont nous avons
besoin pour le redéploiement et la
transition écologique comme alstom se
trouve dans la situation dans laquelle
et parce qu'elle n'a pas été assez
capitalisées pourquoi la banque
d'investissement n'intervient pas pour
prendre la relève
au lieu de vendre cette entreprise soit
à son concurrent allemand ce qui serait
une catastrophe sociale et économique
soit à l'entreprise nord-américaine qui
la convoite pour des raisons qui sont
propres aux regroupements keith levene
un pôle emploi du temps john hurley
mais moi je vous le pardon ne changeons
pas de sujet nous sommes en train de
dire pourquoi celui qui se prétend
obsédé par la question du chômage et qui
feraient mieux de réfléchir le net
obsédé et bien pourquoi ne fait-il rien
quand un des fleurons de l'industrie
française va disparaître comme pourquoi
ne fait il rien l'état ne va pas entrer
dans le capital mais noté c'est encore
pire que tout n'est ce pas pourquoi
l'état notre heure est il pas au capital
pourquoi la nationalisation
n'aurait-elle pas lieu pourquoi notre
sidérurgie et elle a baissé
pourquoi notre industrie électronique
comme celle qui est alcatel lucent
pourquoi l'état at il laissé alcatel
s'endetter auprès de goldman sach pour
un milliard et demi en déposant 29 mille
brevets tout le savoir industrielle de
la france dans ce domaine donc le chef
de l'état a une attitude d'abandon parce
que il est aveuglé par l'idéologie
néolibérale il pense que le marché
règlera tous et qu'à la fin ça finira
par s'arranger au passage la france est
en train de se faire rayer de la carte
des grandes puissances industrielles la
france est en train de se faire rayer de
la carte des nations indépendantes qui
sont en état d'opérer des médiations
lorsqu'il ya des conflits dans le monde
comme on le voit en ukraine vous parlez
de compétitivité il parlait de parts de
marché à qui seront les parts de marché
ont dit que c'était cela dans souffre
aujourd'hui alstom en france non c'est
alors là vous me tendait une perche que
je vous remercie de me tendre
non alstom n'est victime que d'une seule
et unique sur le carnet de commandes
d'alstom est plein alstom n'est pas
assez capitalisées et alstom souffre du
fait que les politiques d'austérité des
états en europe interdisent les
investissements lourds dont on aurait
besoin pour la transition énergétique
mais ce n'est pas tout elle est aussi
victime de la libéralisation du marché
de l'énergie parce que comme c'est un
marché c'est le moins coûtant qui
obtient le marché par conséquent les
grandes entreprises productrices
d'électricité n'investissent pas et par
conséquent n'achète pas les nouvelles
machines
voilà pourquoi le stum et victimes de
l'austérité et du libéralisme en aucun
cas de la compétitivité attendait
monsieur gossio c'est vous qui avez posé
le problème
dites moi quel est le problème de
compétitivité d'alstom y at il un prêt
avec le coût du travail comme ils disent
non pas du tout personne ne se plaint de
sa part contre moi je vous dit les yeux
dans les yeux il ya un problème du coût
du capital
parce que si les premiers qui ont vendu
alstom avait pas siphonné la trésorerie
si monsieur bouygues après avoir
encaissé comme tous les autres
actionnaires
5 milliards 800 millions en cinq ans qui
manquent aujourd'hui dans la caisse
dalton il les a encaissées en dividendes
ne les avaient pas pris si on avait
investi vous ne riez pas d'enfer alstom
aujourd'hui donc c'est bien la preuve
que c'est le coût du capital
est ce que vous vous êtes impressionné
est-ce que vous saluer le travail et
l'implication de d'arnaud montebourg
dans le dossier par exemple ce que vous
lui faites un sort particulier je ne
sera pas juste c'est 1 2 c'est une
équipe c'est un gouverneur donc si nous
regardons d'un peu près personne ne fait
rien par des mots je veux dire florange
a bel et bien été fermés que je sache
alcatel n'a pas été recapitalisée grâce
à l'action de la banque d'investissement
alstom on approche jusque-là le pays
notre avocat selon vous est-ce que pour
vous
l'arrivée de manuel valls à matignon
vous a donné l'occasion vous donne
l'occasion d'aiguiser encore plus vos
critiques déguisées encore plus je ne
crois pas parce que il y aura une
certaine injustice
après tout le plan d'austérité de 50
milliards c'est pas le plan de valls
c'est le plan des ro de toute façon il
avait annoncé avant non valls représente
un pari politique du chef de l'état qui
a analysé les résultats des élections
municipales de la manière suivante il
s'est dit bien le peu le pays votent à
droite je lui donne comme premier
ministre que j'ai de plus à droite dans
mon parti
quand je dis ce que j'ai de plus à
droite dans mon parti ce n'est pas une
appréciation personnelle
c'est l'appréciation qui avait été fait
en son temps par martine aubry elle même
qui avait demandé à valls ou bien tu
arrêtes où tu quittes le parti social
lorient préféré à un client je n'ai pas
d'avis sur le sujet ce n'est pas une
affaire de personne c'est une affaire de
lits une politique
ces personnes sont individuellement
respectable ô combien ce n'est pas le
sujet le sujet c'est quelle est la ligne
politique que l'on applique temps qu'on
applique la politique d'austérité
la france va dans le mur nous sommes une
nation qui moins qu'une autre a intérêt
à une politique de sous capitalisation
sous-investissement sous intervention de
l'état dans l'économie
jean luc mélenchon vous appelle et par
des députés socialistes rondeurs à des
41 qui n'ont pas voté le plan
d'économies de manuel valls à vous
rejoins composent une
nouvelle majorité jory tc s'avère en
effet le front de gauche d'abord et
c'est l'objectif que ça se doit de faire
tomber le gouvernement
non ces deux c'est une sortie positive
parce que le gouvernement il va tomber
tout seul il suffit de faire une
élection
mettez vous savez aussi bien que moi de
quoi valls at il menacé
les députés qui ne voulait qu'ils
voulaient voter contre ou qu'ils
voulaient s'abstenir il leur a dit si
vous ne le faites pas nous dissoudre on
est la menace et que s'ils disent 'on la
droite et l'extrême droite l'emportent
aussitôt le sait on le regarde dans les
études donc moi je ne suis pas un
aventurier
je ne propose pas le saccage c'est
pourquoi je propose une sortie positive
une autre majorité à l'intérieur même
cette assemblée un autre centre de
gravité à gauche pour faire une autre
politique
vous avez des ralliements déjà en vue
nous attendait prenons d'abord les
choses comme elles sont parce que je
crois que les commentateurs ne ne
regarde pas d'assez près ce qui vient de
se passer
valls a été choisi pour réduire la crise
de confiance et élargir la base
d'actions du président de la république
à peine arrive t-il les verts quittent
le gouvernement
puis passe dans votre d'abstention à un
vote contre à l'occasion de son plan
économique
dans le même temps 10 députés 11 députés
commencent par ne pas voter la confiance
et la fois d'après il passe à 41
d'accord et là cette fois ci nous venons
en plus le valve vient en plus de perdre
la mrc autrement dit la base politique
de l'actuel gouvernement qui était
pourtant là pour élargir cette base
réduite
oui il a une majorité relative et on
nous offre comme perspective un meilleur
dialogue entre socialistes je respecte
parfaitement le droit des socialistes de
dialoguer entre eux mais honnêtement ce
n'est pas le sujet
la france ne peut pas être pendus à la
qualité du dialogue que les socialistes
entre eux il faut une nouvelle coalition
est d'ailleurs valls est à chercher
d'istres mais attendez va ne cessez pas
de dissolution
valls est en train de chercher cette
nouvelle coalition il est en train de la
chercher avec le centre
traditionnellement pour la droite du
parti socialiste le centre est l'allié
naturel
moi je propose que les socialistes est
une alliance de gauche et que donc on
change entièrement le dispositif
c'est à dire qu'on tienne tête aux
allemands qu'on arrête avec la politique
d'austérité que l'on relance l'activité
du pays sur les bases du développement
écologique parce que c'est là qu'a
besoin de milliards pour faire changer
la nature de la production d'énergie
et de l'échangé etc etc voilà ce qu'il
faut faire c'est une politique qui
forment un programme j'admets qu'on ne
veuille pas mais c'est mon devoir de le
proposer
et c'est mon devoir de dire aux
socialistes qui ont quand même mordu le
trait si vous me permettez peut dire
quand on décide de ne pas voter la
confiance à un gouvernement de refuser
son plan économique on peut pas ensuite
rentré à la maison est dit là bas on
verra la prochaine fois de quelle
manière on sera remarqué non ils doivent
eux aussi faire une proposition positive
avait des contacts avec certains députés
ps mais si j'en ai je ne vous le dirais
pas parce que ce sont des choses qui ont
besoin disons une certaine
confidentialité pour pouvoir fonctionner
alors il faut que les dialogues
oui pour que les préventions sa baisse
mais monsieur gros sur j'insiste nous
avons tous des responsabilités
politiques devant notre pays
ce n'est pas un jeu le pays va très mal
les gens souffrent d'une manière inouïe
par conséquent les 41 ans qui ont dit
qu'ils ne voulaient pas de cette
politique économique ont le devoir d'en
proposer une autre et c'est pourquoi je
leur dis si vous entreposé une autre et
qui est une politique de gauche
vous aurez des données dans la seconde
après j'ai des appels sur tout et on
verra ce qu ils vous répondront mais
mort à trégunc aimablement vous aurait
conduit à augmenter
christian paul n'a pas dit n'a pas eu
les mots violents mon caca urvoy tsonga
a rendez-vous important tous les cas ce
sera le 22 mai puisque les députés front
de gauche vont déposer une proposition
de loi pour dire stop aux négociations
entre l'europe et les états unis
actuellement sur le libre-échange avoir
parlé dans un instant est-ce qu'on va
parler de votre combat européen monsieur
mélenchon et vous vous appuyez notamment
donc sur ce traité transatlantique mais
également sur le dossier alstom dont
convient d'évoquer mais on voit ça avec
le reportage de faustine saint geniès
avant d'accueillir donc à tel prix jean
de la fp solidarité
salarié de cette entreprise à peine
quelques militants pour cette opération
qui se voulait coup de poing
si hier matin le front de gauche
présente ses têtes de listes aux
élections européennes pour l'île de
france devant le siège d'alstom
objectif pour le député européen patrick
le hyaric montrer que l'europe actuelle
va à l'encontre des intérêts de la
france
cette entreprise est un concentré de ce
que nous ne voulons pas c'est à dire les
effets de la mondialisation capitaliste
le fait que les institutions européennes
ne protège pas nos atouts industriels
meeting des têtes de listes à nanterre
le front de gauche opte pour un
positionnement simple dans cette
campagne être la gauche opposée à
l'austérité
ici on récuse les ticket d'euro
sceptiques mais on fait de l'europe un
bouc émissaire c'est l'europe des
marchés c'est l'europe de la finance ce
que nous proposent leur pacte le mans
c'est la dégringolade on en tombe dans
la ruine regarde ce qui se passe en
italie en grèce pour moi est ce ces
listes actuelles ne sont ne sont pas de
gauche a donc il n'y a que son gauche
pour y arriver
si la sortie de l'euro est
définitivement écarté le front de gauche
appellent à rompre et refondre l'europe
tic-tac désobéir aux traités comme le
résume la numéro 2 sur la liste est
avocate de jean luc mélenchon raquel
garrido
nous sommes le nom de gauche du tc de
2005 consommer non de gauche à françois
hollande
et on est le nom
gauche au grand marché transatlantique
le grand marché transatlantique c'est
d'ailleurs le principal cheval de
bataille du front de gauche est
farouchement opposé à ce traité de libre
échange entre l'union européenne et les
etats unis en cours de négociation à
bruxelles
difficile pourtant pour le parti de
faire entendre sa voix dans cette
campagne éclair à trois semaines à peine
des élections européennes
voilà qu'à tel présent est avec nous
bonsoir chers consoeur de la sp jean luc
mélenchon vous écoute et vous répond à
l'organe voir vous en avait déjà parlé
tout à l'heure avec michel sur alstom
on y revient quand même de deux ans est
ce que l'état a raison de demander des
garanties supplémentaires à génériques
ça signifie qui capitule mois comprenez
c'est son point de vue c'est le point de
vue des libéraux dans le style de
hollande ou de valse 10 rebonds dans les
entreprises et le marché vont régler
tout ça pas mon point de vue moi je suis
pour qui un pôle public de l'énergie
dans lequel on sache produire toutes les
machines dont on a besoin pour le grand
plan écologique dont j'ai besoin pour
l'idée que je me fais du développement
écologique de notre pays alors après si
vous me posez la question précise des
garanties qu'ils demandent je peux pas
trouver une méthode qui revient à
admettre le fait que la somme sera vendu
je ne le veux pas ce qui est sûr c'est
que entre les deux siemens et general
electric on peut dire la chose plus
entre siemens et general electric en
pire
mais moi je ne veux pas de ça je vais
vous dire ça me fend le coeur je pense
en ce moment à cuenca une ville de
l'équateur alstom vient d'envoyer 80
travailleurs du très haut niveau on va
installer le tramway le plus gros
tramway d'amérique du sud
c'est la vitrine des français en
amérique du sud imaginez-vous quand on
va leur dire à ben maintenant c'est le
tramway des gringos non c'est pas
possible on peut pas faire une chose
pareille
c'est la france que voulez vous c'est
l'identité industrielle de la france
bon ça la france est l'épicé pas
seulement les parfums et la tour eiffel
c'est une industrie puissante c'est
quelque chose justement d'européens à
ben certainement pas siemens n'a pas
l'intention faire quelque chose
d'européens vous rêvez d'autant qu'il y
aura le grand marché transatlantique
dont tout ça ça n'existe plus si même de
faire du gros siemens et que propose
siemens de nous refiler son train qui ne
marche pas parce que la vérité c'est
qu'alstom bas siemens chaque fois qu'il
s'agit d'un contrat de trains et vous
avez cas ici de mon temps entre un
allemand fabriqué par siemens et vous
aurez une idée de ce que ça peut être
contraint aux arrivées et départs
aléatoire
que à simone se débarrasse de la branche
la plus endettée et la moins performante
en échange de quoi ils rachètent toute
la branche énergie au moment où le monde
entier se prépare à faire une
bifurcation du modèle énergétique
vous savez que la seule station de d
owlient offshore c'est-à-dire en mer
posé sur des sur des piles qui a en face
d'une côte des états unis d'amérique
c'est alstom qui la réalise donc il
s'agit d'un d'un fleuron quelque chose
qui est beau et grands qui nous permet
de développer des techniques et aciers
spéciaux les pales d'une turbine ccc
quelque chose comme pour cela une
turbine de deux barrages c'est des
choses qui font trois quatre cinq six
sept mètres de haut
et c'est réglé au micro ce sont des à
ses fins donc c'est vraiment c'est pas
tout le dire alstom et un plomb il faut
se rendre compte de l'intelligence
technique a dans toutes ses machines
pas question de lâcher ça aux autres
autres sujets européens qui vous est
cher le traité transatlantique
le 22 mai michel ladi le front de gauche
dépose une loi pour dire stop aux
négociations
c'est aussi un point où vous vous
rejoignez avec les écologistes
oui alors d'abord c'est la bonne
nouvelle parce qu'au départ les
écologistes n'étaient pas sur cette
position en 2002 vous savez d'abord
comme qu'on dise une chose cette
histoire est incroyable parce que ça se
négocie depuis 1995 et personne n'a
jamais entendu parler si bien qu'en 2009
j'avais sorti une première brochure qui
est l'équivalent de celle qu'on vient de
rééditer
mais au bout d'un moment je me suis dit
mais c'est moi qui dois exagérer ce pas
possible personne n'en parle ça
n'intéresse personne
et puis tout d'un coup en janvier 2013
le président obama doit faire un grand
marché et à ce moment-là d'affaires
s'est accélérée et à ce moment-là marché
en train de l'europe et des états doit
là un marché unique où il y aurait un
peu comme on a fait en adressant à des
choses à gagner
non un peu comme on a fait entre les 28
non mais je termine de répondre et
ensuite je vous réponds mais déjà je
vous réponds non et je filme la répond
la bonne nouvelle c'est que les
écologistes au départ cohn bendit en
2002 a voté pour
et maintenant les écologistes sont
contre on voit donc qu'il ya une
convergence qui s'opère entre le front
de gauche qui est sûr le nom depuis 2009
et les écolos graal nouveau terrain où
on se retrouve ensemble sont surtout
sensibles aux questions
l'environnement bien sûr parce que les
normes environnementales seront les
mêmes des deux côtés de l'atlantique
évidemment c'est toujours les plus
basses qui prévalent parce que sinon ils
font pas un grand marché les américains
font pas ça pour introduire de la
social-démocratie ans aux usa donc les
normes environnementales seront les plus
basses pour nous les européens c'est
grave parce que ça veut dire les
produits ogm ça veut dire le boeuf aux
hormones ça veut dire on sort toujours
cet exemple parce qu'il fait un peu
sourire
nous nous l'avons les poulets tuer avec
nos méthodes avec les normes sanitaires
en matière d'alimentation sont excusés
de ce faux et ben écoutez je sais pas
qui vous a dit ça à la nation qu'est le
candidat ump d'année cela alors je sais
pas si j'ai un ump qui le dit c'est donc
que c'est vrai mais en attendant le
commissaire européen chargé de la
question a dit qu'il fallait arrêter de
l'embêter avec cette histoire de poulet
laver à la javel aux états unis
d'amérique parce que m'avait pas laissée
terminée et il a dit eh ben il y aura
quand même des étiquettes et ceux qui
voudront pas de poulet à la javel
mangeront les autres mais le poulet
javel coûtera nécessairement moins cher
pour la raison qu'il est nettoyée avec
des méthodes
je vous fais grâce du détail donc les
écolos sont sensibles à ça
nous aussi nous avons une divergence
avec eux c'est qu'on leur dit ben
écoutez comment pouvez vous être
sensible à l'alignement par le bas des
normes et en même temps voté toutes les
mesures de libéralisation du marché de
l'énergie
bon on a des contradictions ne pas dire
on dit pas les choses de la même manière
nous nous sommes absolument contre le
libre-échange et lost et non attendez
de quoi ne sommes pas contre tous nous
sommes pour la mairie nous sommes pour
le bonheur nous sommes bien dans les
propositions parce qu'on dit que la
définition des normes essentielles dans
les mélanges là pour gagner mais on
connaît conquérir des marchés voilà
c'est ça qu'on crée alors est ce assez
fausse et oui c'est absurde mais
monsieur gossio on a peut-être quand
même le droit de se demander si c'est
une bonne idée de créer un marché unique
est ce qu'on a le droit ou pas est-ce
que c'était évident est ce que le but
dans la vie c'est de développer les
parts de marché sur le dos de qui s'il
vous plaît vous savez très bien que ce
ne sont pas les normes qui empêche les
parts de marché l'énorme servent de
barrage protectionnistes aux états unis
face à l'europe l'europe a abaissé
toutes ses frontières
toutes ces barrières d'accord donc de
quoi parle-t-on de celle des états unis
d'amérique donc le but dans la vie c'est
d'entrer sur le marché des états unis
d'amérique mais nous y sommes déjà
je vous ferai remarquer et nous
pourrions nous mettre des normes
environnementales qui empêchent certains
produits dentaires
donc s'il vous plaît de grâce ne
retournez pas la situation avec le cette
espèce de tarte à la crème ce refrain
d'après lequel dès qu'on crée un grand
marché ça développe la croissance
l'activité l'emploi bla bla bla bla rien
de tout ça ne s'est jamais produit je
suis parlementaire européen j'ai vu
passer au moins 15 accords de libre
échange avec telle ou telle zone du
monde à chaque foyer marquer nous aurons
un point de croissance 052 si on faisait
le total on serait à 50 % de croissance
qui serait vraiment très mauvais pour la
planète
rien de tout ça ne se produira la vérité
que les nord américains veulent très un
grand marché unique parce que depuis
tantôt 30 ans ils ont un objectif
constituer un bloc occidental et c'est
ça leur objectif et géopolitique
il n'est pas économique parce que rien
aujourd'hui n'a empêché les américains
d'acheter des entreprises françaises
mais les entreprises françaises
d'acheter des entreprises américaines
donc du point de vue du capital n'y a
pas de problème c'est du point de vue du
travail et de la qualité de vie durant
très grand problème
alstom le traite transatlantique est ce
que quand même le pouvoir politique
encore du poids bien sûr on pouvoir
économique évidemment sauf s'il renonce
alstom par exemple nous pourrions
décider que c'est une entreprise
stratégique
il ya des lois qui permettent de dire ah
bah écoutez la france intervient on
n'est pas agressif on dit à siemens on
vous remercie d'avoir fait une offre
on dit à general electric on vous
remercie d'avoir fait une ont surtout de
general electric est une entreprise très
implanté en france donc il n'est pas
question de se mettre en guerre avec
general electric et puis on dit mais un
saumon sauvegarde et on crée d'ailleurs
en pôle public
on pourrait créer un pôle public marié
avec cette entreprise dont le nom
m'échappe à l'instant qui fabrique des
aciers spéciaux et qui elle aussi est en
liquidation
or c'est assez spéciaux sont nécessaires
pour de telles réalisations etc
et c'est donc le l'intervention de
l'état est toujours possible c'est la
capitulation qui fait qu'il y en a pas
mais personne n'oblige hollande à ne pas
intervenir
au contraire si j'étais moi le
responsable de la politique du pays
cette affaire sera réglée
de même qu alcatel n'aurait jamais été m
ces brevets en garantie à goldman sach
mais au contraire l'état aurait un
milliard et demi de capital engagé dans
cette entreprise
voilà il y adeux le libéralisme ne tombe
pas du ciel
le marché ne tombe pas du ciel il est
volontairement organisé par des gens qui
pensent que c'est comme ça que
l'humanité va mieux et moi je crois
qu'ils font une absurdité
permettez moi quand même de rajouter un
mot écologique qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire
alors donc maintenant déménagé le monde
transbahuter des marchandises d'un côté
à l'autre de l'atlantique c'est ça
l'avenir un monde fini dans les
ressources sont finies et tout ce qui
nous intéresse est déménagée circulait
produire à moindre prix augmenter la
taille des navires qui transportent de
plus en plus se réjouir de voir la
calotte glaciaire fond parce que les
navires de plus en plus large peuvent
passer par la féliciter l'instant des
succès à l'exportation d'alstom mais
pardon ça n'est pas pareil qu'une
entreprise installe parce que elle
qu'elle installe ses productions qui
sont des des productions comme nous
sommes des éoliennes aux états unis et
d'organiser le déménagement au général
du monde mais maintenant monsieur
grossiord je veux bien vous dire que
nous pourrions décider que le matériel
énergétique ne s'exporte pas ce serait
absurde parce que des millions de gens
ont besoin de ce matériel et ne sont pas
en état de le produire par contre
permettez moi de vous dire que des
poulets tout le monde peut en produire
et que le riz tout le monde n'est pas
obligé d'en manger le blé tout on n'est
pas obligés d'en manger parce qu'il ya
des pays où ça serait mieux de plantes
et du sorgho et continuer les cultures
traditionnelles qui seront écrasés par
ses exportations
voilà voilà la vérité et comme on a bien
compris les différents combats que vous
menez dans la perspective de ce scrutin
européen qui a également vous n'avez pas
bien conscience que est ce que je peux
dire quels sont les réseaux remplissez
votre voiture
merci merci je vais prochainement sur
donc en fait on vote trois choses pardon
on peut avoir des débats sans fin sur
l'europe et donc on connaît sa position
sur françois hollande par exemple est-ce
que vous déplorez aussi que ce matin il
n'est pas parlé d'europe justement à
bord je pense que il aurait dû on voit
bien que pour lui c'est un non sujet
puisque toute façon on n'aura pas fait
ce que dit madame merkel donc pour lui
ce pas un sujet je déplore l'abaissement
sa pensée parce que quand on a en tout
et pour tout comme slogan plus vite plus
fort qu'on le répète cinq fois bon et on
n'est pas aux jeux olympiques là on
n'est pas en train d'organiser une
course on est en train d'organiser la
vie d'un pays et deuxièmement
l'abaissement de sa pensée quand il dit
l'entreprise france non la france n'est
pas une entreprise ne se gère pas comme
une entreprise
ce n'est pas vrai que la france a failli
déposer son bilan c'est un mensonge
la france n'est pas du tout en état de
déposer un bilan la france est plus
riche qu'elle ne l'a jamais été
son histoire ils essayent de nous passer
le vocabulaire de la droite économique
et je trouve déplorable de la part d'un
président de la république alors pour
les élections pardon de vous dire nous
avons cette fois ci un contenu concret
chaque député votera oui ou non au grand
marché transatlantique ce n'est pas le
cas avant mais là il va voter
deuxièmement chaque député devra choisir
un président de la commission soit c'est
monsieur juncker
le prototype du libéral soit c'est le
martin schulz socialiste qui gouverne
avec madame merkel en allemagne soit
c'est monsieur bové soit c'est monsieur
qui pressent le héros de la résistance
grecque que nous soutenons nous comme
candidat à l'élection à la commission
européenne comme la question petite
question
marine le pen qui dit vouloir constituer
une minorité de blocage pour éviter l'
austérité qui table sur 20 à 25 députés
européens le front de gauche en a qu'ont
3 4 4 4
elle est là désespoir de gala c'est
payons pour l électoralement de dénoncer
l'austérité
pourquoi cette différence bon d'abord
commençons par dire si vous voulez bien
que pour l'instant ils sont trois et
nous 5
non mais parce que vous comparer notre
situation actuelle avec leurs espoirs de
demain donc c'est juste pour rétablir
l'information aux trois ans 8 oui oui
bien sûr oui oui on a compris on a
compris vous inquiétez pas on a bien
compris ce que vous cherchez à faire
alors ensuite nous avons écouté monsieur
vous comparez une réalité d'aujourd'hui
avec une projection pour demain à leur
bord oui c'est bien ce que vous venez de
faire ça m'amuse moi ça me contrarie oui
oui alors maintenant on va regarder
n'ont rien donné comment pourquoi
you may réputé mois il supporter que
vous vous des masques de temps à autre
maintenant on annonce
il est dit que le groupe b auquel
j'appartiens pourrait être le troisième
de cette assemblée
cette information qui n'est pas sur un
bien sûr c'est un sondage comme pour
madame le pen raille oui voilà donc
c'est un sondage mais en attendant on
dit le groupe b pour être le troisième
est donc la candidature d'alexis chypre
as prendra tout de suite un impact dans
le parlement européen qui sera
considérable après là vous me posez la
question de savoir pourquoi elle s'est
aussi contre l'austérité
ce dont je me réjouis elle qui est aussi
contre le grand marché transatlantique
ce dont je me réjouis parce que fait
madame le pen sur ces sujets en quelque
sorte
elle élargit le consensus national
hostile à l'autorité hostile aux
politiques libérales
hostile au grand marché transatlantique
et aux états unis d'amérique je n'ai
quand même pas pleurer
bon alors pourquoi elle at elle des
sondages meilleurs que les nôtres
eh bien peut-être monsieur grossiord
pourriez-vous je sais pas à tout hasard
un os comme ça constaté qu'il ya une
différence entre une organisation de
gauche est une organisation d'extrême
droite déjà ça fait une différence
la deuxième différence c'est que eux
sont là le lobby le pen père fils et
petites filles et petits et arrière
petits enfants depuis 40 ans nous nous
existons depuis cinq ans deuxièmement
même traversons à mesure que nous
avançons des difficultés d'ajustement de
stratégie qui fait que des fois on est
un peu illisible je ne vais pas dire le
contraire
donc ce sont nos difficultés et enfin
nous ne sommes pas racistes nous ne
sommes pas être consiste et par
conséquent il est plus difficile de
comprendre que le responsable de nos
malheurs c'est le financier le banquier
plutôt que de croire que celle immigrés
madame le pen dispose à son à son
service du simplisme et de la haine des
autres bombes a apparemment son fond de
commerce est là mais dois-je devenir
raciste ethniciste pour réussir non
jamais et vous avez vu que dans mon
discours de mme strager vous avez vu
dans mon discours de marseille en pleine
campagne présidentielle
j'ai dit ce qu'il y avait à dire c'est à
l'avenir de la france et des mélanges
dont l effet avec vous avertir sur la
méditerranée on se souvient de ce
discours merci katell c'est perrine
tarneaud arrive maintenant on va parler
notamment de l'ukraine un dossier très
sensible et très important également des
attaques contre le volant c'est contre
des journaux les agissements de certains
de nos confrères
selon vous de georgie ce manque est
assez le mot d'abord question de style
de jean luc mélenchon le tribun en quête
de samir déchirage fait curieux de voir
ça qu'ils le flou nous viserons le maire
avec les marches du palais qu'ils s'en
aillent tous
c'est le tribun par excellence des
discours de plusieurs heures sans notes
mais truffé de références
jean luc mélenchon excelle dans l'art de
fasciner son auditoire
il a toujours été un des meilleurs
orateurs du parti socialiste parce qu'il
a le sens de la formule et puis il a le
sens de la gestuelle jean luc mélenchon
c'est un tribun aucune source de la 3ème
et la 4ème république c'est quelqu'un
qui est qui met beaucoup d'émotion donc
ce quelqu'un qui met de la colère en
particulier cette colère là on fait elle
est en phase avec ce qu'attendent les
gens aujourd'hui il ya une très forte
colère dans la société française une
colère qui s'exprime aussi sur les
plateaux télé hyper médiatique jean luc
mélenchon sait faire le buzz à coups de
formules chocs
est ce que vous vous êtes prêt à
déclarer votre patrimoine pour qu'on
s'assure que rien dans votre patrimoine
fait que vous êtes gêné pour me poser
certaines questions écouté mon espèce
d'hypocrites de médias il ya une
stratégie médiatique jean luc mélenchon
à tort à mon avis parce qu'il a de
meilleur qualité que cela choisit
souvent la transgression c'est-à-dire
frapper fort ont frappé les imaginations
et donc du coup ça amène un discours qui
porte en lui une certaine violence et
marine le pen ma part tant d'autres
prémices aussi un discours violent une
violence commune dans le discours mais
la comparaison s'arrête là car du côté
de jean luc mélenchon pas de
simplification à l'extrême dans la
formulation mais a eu des tas stupéfait
quand marine le pen les gens vous moi
tout le monde comprend et comprennent 80
% de ce que dit marine le pen
spontanément sans avoir besoin de
réfléchir avec les jean luc mélenchon
parce que son vocabulaire est élaborée
parce que ces références sont
compliquées élitiste ça va tomber à 16
18 20 % donc si vous voulez entre 80 %
et 20 % il ya quand même un gros gros
gap et c'est ça qui explique que jean
luc mélenchon n'arrive pas à embrayer
avec l'électorat en général c'est que il
n'est pas au bon niveau
tribun populaire n'est peut-être pas
assez populistes une différence qui pèse
son poids dans les résultats électoraux
aux européennes du 25 mai le front
national est donnée en tête bien devant
le front de gauche
voilà j'ai avec mêlant chant et c'est
perrine tarneaud qui vous interroge
maintenant mélenchon ne simplifiait pas
assez finalement jean luc mélenchon est
ce que vous partagez cette analyse bon
j'ai d'abord c'est une analyse qui est
respectueuse donc je la gelée coûte
j'entends ce qu'on dit mais vous savez
en pleine campagne présidentielle
j'avais eu une petite remarque de
quelqu'un que j'estime en dépit du fait
que je ne suis pas d'accord avec tout
comme alain bergounioux qui est un
esprit extrêmement puissants dans le
mouvement socialiste c'était madame mona
ozouf t avais dit mélenchon est trop
intellectuel pour ceux à qui il parle
je pense qu'elle se trompe le grand
nombre des français comprend
parfaitement ce qui se dit et c'est un
peuple libre dont qui choisit d'un côté
ou de l'autre
et comme réplique à madame mona ozouf
que je respecte encore une fois
brillante historienne j'avais dit aux
gens et écouter ce soir à faire ce que
personne fait je vais vous lire un poème
j'ai eu deux pages de poésie de victor
hugo les gens avaient les yeux qui
brillaient applaudi à tout rompre
victor hugo bien sûr pas moi mais
surtout l'idée que quelqu'un ne les
prenez pas pour des imbéciles il faut
pas prendre les gens pour des imbéciles
nous avons un sujet vous croyez que je
suis un compréhensible alors je pense
que je pense que je suis compréhensible
j'admets que les idées que je développe
par contre nécessite des fois j'en suis
confus par c'est pour ça que je parte en
jeu si bavard dans mes meetings
parce que j'essaye d'expliquer tout bien
en détails parce que je me dis mais les
gens n'ont pas n'ont pas que ça à faire
dans la journée
c'est pour ça qu'ils m'ont élu c'est
pour leur expliquer donc c'est le
travail après que voulez vous c'est la
lente le long travail de l'histoire
l'histoire est lente et cruel
c'est bien le problème mais nous les
gens de gauche nous avons toujours été à
creuser le sillon dans les difficultés
vous savez les moments de gloire ont été
rares dans l'histoire on arrive au
gouvernement de temps à auch par la
gauche a repris aujourd'hui elle est
devenu sauvage
vous voyez c'est à dire que vous êtes
vite installée dans un rôle vous êtes
vite poussé au bout de vous même il ya
des méthodes
de travail de du journalisme qui pousse
les gens à bout mais on n'est pas
toujours préparés à ça vous comprenez
quand par exemple certains certains
comme des rémissions leur truc c'est
d'être présent de vous coller un micro
sous le nez toute la journée où vous
posez dix fois la même question jusqu'à
ce que vous craquiez moi je reconnais je
n'ai pas le nerfs d'acier je ne suis pas
encore devenu le robot qu'il faudrait
être pour faire face à cette situation
j'ai le tort de me passionner jeu j'en
conviens mais je me passionne c'est ce
qui explique que cette semaine encore si
on va de black vous en net retrait aux
journalistes du monde et de libération
du monde seulement ouais enfin
libération vous les citer aussi vous
appelez en tout cas concernant le
journalisme les journalistes du monde
vous appelez vos amis c'est ce que vous
dites sur votre blog elle est surveillée
de façon étroite et à filmer parce que
c'est big brother
enfin bon écoutez c'est big brother pour
moi toute la journée il ya des caméras
ça va le ce sont des militants
politiques le monde mène une action
permanente contre moi des photos
diffamante insultante 30 fois le même
portrait de moi a publié dans leurs
différentes éditions çà va donc le monde
a une position politique c'est un
militant politique ce journal donc il
reçoit une réponse de militants j'ai
essayé vous savez de faire la paix avec
de trouver un modus vivendi je vais vous
dire comment j'ai proposé trois
conditions pour avoir un entretien chez
eux
1 un type qui a un rapport avec le sujet
de une photo qui ne soit pas insultante
3 la moitié des questions sur la détente
par exemple une photo où on va me durcir
tous les traits me prendre en gros plan
au moment où je chante l'internationale
j'ai donc la bouche grande ouverte et on
voit jusqu'à mes chaussettes dans ma
bouche c'est ça des photos ou insultant
je n'ai pas amené le document si vous
m'aviez dit que vous m'interrogez sur le
sujet je vous l'aurais montrer je n'ai
pas supporté d'être mis à la une du
monde dans les mêmes positions aux
adorateurs et une bande comme comme
comme celle d'adolphe hitler je n'ai pas
supporté
je suis un homme de gauche on a le droit
de détester toutes mes idées mais pas
d'insultés ma personne ni de n'avoir
aucun respect pour ma dignité dans le
cas qui nous occupe
pourquoi j'ai réagi une fois de plus
parce que mon camarade gabriel a marqué
la tête de liste dans la région du grand
est et allait démarrer le démarrage de
sa caravane devant le stum alors ils ont
discuté avec les gens ils ont comme on
le fait rien que de très normal en plus
vous vous doutez que dans le store dans
l'instant nous avons beaucoup d'amis non
c'est pas celui ci c'était une autre
situation là-bas à belfort bon vous vous
doutez qu'il ya beaucoup de gens du
front de gauche à l'intérieur de
d'alstom s'est passé pas une découverte
dont claire la ration très bonne et par
quoi commence le papier par le fait
qu'on est mal garées que ça gêne les
ouvriers bon ça va dans l'arctique est
ce que c'est vrai que vous êtes d'accord
pour dire que c'est blessant messieurs
ont reçu encore vous désirez être jugé
tout est enfin monté sur des titres
digbeu ce n'est pas d'aujourd'hui que
raï et ça n'est pas dangereux demandez à
vos militants de d'entraver le travail
de nos confrères mais on n'en trouve pas
est ce que mon travail est entravée par
le fait qu'on colle une caméra toute la
journée du matin au soir
comme l'ont fait à plusieurs auditions
bah oui ce sont des mid en réponse à des
cerfs-volants politiques publiques un
wiki vous en gagnant attendez moi je
suis un homme privé une activité
publique
donc je n'accepte pas d'être insultée
dans ma dimension d'homme
oui mais les journalistes ne vous suis
pas non plus dans votre vie privée line
up oui madame parce que les avocats
extradé pour sa figurez vous n'est ce
pas parce que j'ai envoyé les avocats
qu'il fallait pour ça pas parce qu'ils
se sont eux-mêmes censuré vous retenu
pendant que nous reste une morale vous
assumez jasmin en six ans messieurs
grossiord j'assume je suis dans une
mêlée avec le journal le monde
nous sommes dans une dispute il ya une
disproportion des moyens gigantesques
vis-à-vis du monde a bien sûr que c'est
de cette nature c'est pour leur dire une
fois de plus un raid ailleurs avec le
journal le monde a un problème de en
interne et madame le gars est il le
dirige crois qu'elle va s'en sortir en
montrant à un ennemi commun
monsieur jean-luc dizier un peu épuisé
par la politique française prêt à jeter
l'épongé
non je re elle m'a dit vous avez l'air
épuisé j'ai dit oui je le suis enfin
j'ai 63 ans et je cours le pays toute
l'année on peut comprendre que je sois
fatigué à l'est et au sud est qui plonge
le pays qui plonge de l'alliance vous
avez vu comment les facistes ont fait
brûler des camarades à l'intérieur de la
maison des syndicats
c'est une honte ouais mais poutine a
réussi son opération de déstabilisation
non écrite mais non les etats-unis sont
arrivés mais sont dépassés par la
situation
alors je sais je connais le numéro je
suis poutinien blâmer tout ça de côté si
on réfléchit sérieusement nous avons
dans cette région du monde la fin de l'
empire soviétique n'a jamais été
négociés
donc les choses se recale bon on a un
terrain et faire preuve d'intelligence
et doux d'esprit pacifique
n'est ce pas c'est le contraire de la
méthode qu'on pratique et les états unis
d'amérique en essayant d'avancer les
frontières de l'otan jusqu'aux portes
des bases russe en crimée bien et c'est
à partir de la vie en essayant de faire
avancer les frontières pardon c'est
aussi ce qu'essaie de faire la russie
aujourd'hui la cdc mortes et on n'est
pas cet avis sinon vous n'avez pas droit
parce que ce n'est pas vrai l'initiative
d' étendre les frontières de l'otan à
l'intérieur de l'ukraine de la crimée
n'est pas venue d'une initiative des
russes mais des nord américains
il se trouve qu'une nouvelle fois en
ukraine comme en géorgie
ils sont débordés par des
ultranationalistes au départ en ukraine
on a une révolte populaire que je
soutiens une révolution sociale contre
les oligarques qui est pourri et les
corrompus qui sont revenus au pouvoir
effectivement quelques nationalistes ou
ici ministre d'extrême droite nationaux
socialistes c'est en détail
imaginez que la même chose arrive chez
monsieur poutine et on verrait ce que
vous diriez alors qu'a fait monsieur
poutine je ne dis pas qu'il a raison il
a fait quelque chose que je n'admets pas
qu'ils aient de transgresser les
frontières
je suis pour qu'on ne touche pas aux
frontières donc si vous me demandez mon
avis d'accord je ne suis pas pour
l'entrée en ukraine mais je dis que le
raisonnement qui consiste à chauffer
matin midi et soir l'opinion contre la
russie en le désignant comme
l'adversaire est une bêtise
nous avons nous les français autre chose
à faire je vous signale que le nombre de
responsables internationaux qui
commencent à dire que cette histoire est
en train de mal tourner et que c'est pas
une bonne idée d'aller se battre au
milieu des centrales nucléaires dont il
faut il faut pardon tu sais
avec aujourd'hui voilà c'est nos
poubelles en bas je pose à gré solutions
saas et sanctions économiques de ce rare
sur nos les sanctions économiques sont
ridicules et absurdes qui propose une
médiation
ça c'est bien mais les sanctions
économiques qui frappent tel ça ne fera
pas la russie c'est une c'est un pays
gigantesque ça nous frappe nous les
européens parce que les allemands des
milliards d'investissements en russie
parce que nous les français
les banques françaises possèdent des
réseaux les entreprises s'inquiète son
deuxième même pas sur la suite
la situation est absurde parce que c'est
une guerre civile au milieu de centrales
nucléaires dois-je rappeler comment la
dernière fois on a réglé le cas de
tchernobyl des milliers des dizaines de
milliers de russes on allait mourir pour
empêcher le corps de d'exploser et toute
l'europe d'être contaminé par conséquent
ce n'est pas être un poutinien que de
dire qu'il ne faut pas faire la guerre
il ne faut pas faire la guerre il faut
négocier qu'il faut faire des
concessions aussi au risque mais non non
aucune autre que la garantie de leurs
frontières
vous n'avez qu'à lire ce qu'ils écrivent
on ne peut pas lire que ce que dit
monsieur john kerry monsieur john kerry
a dit que la question ukrainienne mettez
en cause l'hégémonie des etats-unis dans
le monde madame est ce que c'est ça que
vous défendez non bien sûr ni moi non
plus nous ne défendons pas l'hégémonie
des nord américains dans l'ain nous
défendons la paix la tranquillité et le
développement harmonieux des peuples est
un pacifiste en aplat évidemment je suis
un pacifique absolue et radicale pas un
pacifiste parce que des fois il faut
défendre sa vie les armes à la main mais
je dis que ce qui se passe en blanc en
ukraine
cette absurde d'aller soutenir les
éléments les plus déchaînés
bien sûr que les russes agissent et se
donnent des garanties bien sûr bien sûr
qu'on ne doit pas approuvé le fait qu'il
viole les frontières mais en attendant
il faut comprendre pourquoi ils agissent
de cette manière si vous voulez qu'une
médiation abouti si vous pensez que
c'est seulement de l'impérialisme vous
ne comprenez rien la situation
les russes veulent se garantir et les
nord-américains les agresse voilà le
fond de la faire au milieu il ya
l'europe quand même il ya un peuple
ukrainien une partie en tous les cas qui
aspire qui déclasse en un sens sa flamme
pour l'europe ça très bien vous avez
aussi la passion l'amour fait avec nous
n'en croit pas un mot
on croyait pas un nom un peu l'ukraine
certainement pas certainement pas nous
allons intégrer l'ukraine à l'union
rentrer c'est ça que vous me dites pas
du tout et ça vous proposez pardon
qu'est-ce que l'ukraine viendra faire
dans l'union européenne n'a pas de la
turquie
on va faire entrer l'ukraine c'est à
dire on ne veut pas d'un pays développé
comme la turquie pour les raisons que
vous connaissez
moi j'en ai eu deux fois pour pas
vouloir la turquie je ne veux pas car
ils 80 millions de gens qui sera à des
conditions sociales inférieur au niveau
moyen de l'europe parce que le jumping
sera développé pour les mêmes raisons je
ne veux pas des ukrainiens et je ne suis
pas d'accord pour dire que nous aurions
l'obligation de prendre en charge une
ukraine dévasté par sa propre bêtise
très bien voilà qui est dit est dit
beaucoup de choses tout est dit ou
presque avec mes lentilles en verre
merci noël à la prochaine foire oui à
bientôt
bien sûr
ouah